-It is time to play
a game of deception
called "True confessions."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Smooth saxophone music plays ]
♪♪
-You can see my first opponent
on her
"Vaccinated and Horny Tour."
Please welcome Chelsea Handler!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome!
-Yeah!
-Chelsea Handler.
Good to see you, buddy.
Chelsea and I will be facing off
against a very talented actor
that you can see in
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife."
Give it up for Finn Wolfhard!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, Finn.
-Good to see you. Chelsea.
-Now, here is --
here is how the game works.
In front of us each
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true.
The other is false. Yeah.
So, now, once you read
your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then you have to come
to a unanimous decision.
Is it the truth or is it a lie?
-Got it.
-Wait. Are you playing?
Looks like
you're playing already.
Are you judging me already?
-No.
I'm just trying
to understand the rules
so I don't get it twisted, okay?
-No, no. Understood. Okay.
I feel like
you're playing hardball.
-Well, you don't have to make
eye contact with me like that.
-I'm making serious --
I've never made
this much eye contact with you.
-Yeah, it's a little creepy.
-Sorry about that.
-Back it up. Would you mind
making eye contact with me?
-I just -- I would rather
my parents not fight on air.
-Oh!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Oh. This --
-Whoa! Coming in hot!
-Chelsea, here we go.
Chelsea, you go first.
-What do you want me
to do, Jimmy?
-All right, which one?
What do you think? One or two?
Which?
-Go two.
-All right. Number two.
-So I read this aloud?
I don't understand
how games work.
-Yeah.
-You read it. That's correct.
I shoplifted lingerie
from Sears.
-Okay.
-So, what year was this?
-Uh, 197-- in '85.
'85. I would have been 10.
I was born in '75.
That was another century.
-Right.
-All right.
So you were in --
Sears was your go-to store to --
to get all your clothes?
-Well, no.
To get most of my appliances.
But I also saw a lingerie
section one there -- one day
with my girlfriend,
and they had a red and --
-Sorry. You were in appliances
as a 10-year-old?
-Well, I went --
-"This is where
I buy all my stuff."
-"Yeah, I need a new blender."
-My parents were shopping there,
and I thought I saw
an opportunity while they were
shopping for their appliances
or whatever you get
at Sears, okay?
I still don't know.
And I saw a little --
not, like, negligee outfit.
A blond bra.
I mean, a red bra that I thought
was gonna look great
with my blond locks
and a matching set of panties.
And even though I was too young,
I thought, "Wow.
This opportunity is gonna come
sooner than one may think."
Right?
-Sure.
-Yeah, so then I got it --
I got --
I stole it, and then, like,
the Sears security came.
It was humiliating, and I had to
go to, like, shoplifting class
with my dad for two weeks
and I had to stand up
every class and say,
"I'm Chelsea Handler,
and I'm a shoplifter."
-[ Laughs ]
-It was like a klepto...
klepto class?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-The alarm was on it?
-Well, yeah. Yeah, exactly.
So, obviously,
you've shoplifted too, Jimmy.
Thank you.
-Yeah.
-You had your year.
-I think I -- I think
I took a Snickers bar once,
but that was a big thing for me.
But, yeah, I know
what you're talking about.
Um. Huh. I -- I --
-Yeah.
I believe -- I somehow --
I believe --
-Yeah, me too.
I believe some of it.
-Yeah.
-But I don't believe it all,
and I don't see you
as -- as someone --
But I think
you're also an adventurer.
So I think you wouldn't --
might like to experience
what shoplifting is.
-Yeah. I think -- I think --
Is it fair to say you have --
Have you shoplifted since then?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-That was a great question.
-Yeah.
-I'm going to say --
I'm going to say "true."
-Yeah, I'll say "true," too.
-Okay. Great.
-And now you're at -- Is it?
-Yeah, it's true.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Were you scared?
-No, no.
I felt like --
No, I wasn't scared.
I felt like
I was earning my stripes.
-Right.
-You know what I mean?
-Or bummed that you got caught.
-I was bummed that I got caught
'cause my mom
was embarrassed for me.
Like, she wouldn't speak to me.
-But out of all the things
to steal, too.
-Well, a bra.
-Sexy lingerie?
-Yeah, and when I was, like,
only 10 years old, like --
-It's funny. I did
the exact same thing at 10.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wait. Here we go.
Now it's my turn.
Which envelope should I open?
-I say --
-It's a sleeper hit of a joke.
-I say -- Yeah.
It's gonna hit any minute.
-I liked it. I liked it.
-Yeah.
-Jimmy Fallon, number one.
You -- Are you Jimmy Fallon?
-That's me.
-Okay.
-You are number one, too.
-Yeah, I appreciate it.
Thanks buddy.
[ Clears throat ]
-We'll see.
-I once crashed a wedding
with Michael Jordan.
-I believe that.
-Yeah, that's --
-Wait! No!
You got to ask questions!
-That's, like,
a weird famous person.
-That would easily happen.
-Okay. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
-You're not even -- You're not
even going to interrogate me?
-No, because
it's obviously true.
-Well, where did you meet
Michael Jordan?
Like, where -- Like --
-I was at a --
-What preceded this?
-Good question.
-Thank you.
-I was at a --
a charity golf tournament.
-That's a lie.
That part is a lie.
That was a lie, and I know
you're lying right now.
That's not how you met him.
It was a different event.
We won't get into the details.
-Derek Jeter's golf tournament.
-Oh, I know this is gonna
line up, this story,
because I've also met
Michael Jordan
and he was with Derek Jeter.
And so I know those two
are always together
because they're buddies.
-All right.
-So I already believe it.
-Whose wedding was it?
-I don't know.
-Oh, you crashed the wedding.
Okay.
-I crashed a stranger's wedding.
-Yeah, and what did you do
when you got to the wedding?
-I tried to get Morgan Freeman
to come with me.
He wouldn't do it.
But I went in.
I just thought it'd be funny.
Because someone said
there was a wedding next door.
I go, "Let's just walk in.
Michael Jordan.
Bring him into a wedding.
It would be funny."
-And see what happens?
-We did a shot, maybe,
with everyone.
I got up with the deejay,
and I --
I started a conga line, but --
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's what I did.
With Michael Jordan.
-Yeah, with Michael Jordan.
-No, he did not do
the conga line.
-Yeah, was he --
-He definitely didn't.
-Was this a thing where, like,
he felt bad
so he kind of
went along with you?
-No, we were fine.
We're having fun. He likes me.
-He didn't, like, bring --
You know, you didn't like,
"Hey, Michael. Come here."
-I don't really remember it
being that desperate.
I think it was more of, like,
a fun idea,
and I go, "Dude, this would
be funny. Let's do this."
And it was the three of us
talking.
I go, "Let's just do it.
Really quick.
Then we'll come right back."
-The Morgan Freeman thing
puzzles me.
-Morgan Freeman is actually
randomly at a lot of places,
you know?
Like, I've also been at parties
where Morgan Freeman
arrives out of nowhere.
-Yeah, I know.
My -- My cousin's third, like,
birthday party, he was there.
It was weird.
He was the clown.
-Yeah, you can hire
Morgan Freeman.
-But we all agree
that this is a real story,
so why are we even
wasting our time?
-All right.
This is a waste of time.
It is not a true story.
I was making it up.
-Oh [bleep]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Morgan Freeman...
I know that.
-Ohh.
[ Indistinct conversation ]
-I am very confused
about this game.
I thought
this had to be something --
Well, actually, I'm not
gonna say what I thought.
Because that's gonna ruin
the rest of the game.
-Yeah. Okay. There you go.
-Okay. I already ruined it.
-The Morgan Freeman thing
really --
That was really, really good.
-That was a good one.
-I was stressing about this
all day.
-Good for you.
Wow. Good acting, Jimmy.
-I broke a sweat. Thank you.
It's the best acting.
You've seen my work.
-Yeah, I've seen it.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, Finn,
what do you think?
Finn Wolfhard.
I say number one.
-Yeah, let's go uno.
-Yeah.
-Cool.
-That's Spanish for "one."
-Yeah, got it. Okay.
-Yeah.
-I once thought it would be cool
to try stage diving
and I immediately broke my foot.
-All right. He's in a band.
I know this.
-Yeah.
-Broke your foot stage diving.
So how did you break --
-How long did it take you
to recover from your...?
-That was, like --
I did physio, actually.
Because I had to do a job.
So that was like six --
six months in and out.
-That's a good question, though.
-I was in a boot for, like --
I was in a -- Six months?
-Yeah, that's a long time.
-My mom is --
-He's only 6 months old.
-Yeah, but --
That's what I mean.
Yeah, but your bones
are so young and strong.
It shouldn't take you
that long to heal.
-I landed on it weird.
-Okay.
-What did you expect to land on?
For people to catch you?
-Yeah.
I -- But -- Somehow I clipped --
So what happens -- You know
the barrier between the stage
and the thing? I clipped it,
hit my ankle on it,
and ended up breaking the --
I guess it would be the middle
of it, and it was a fracture.
-Uh-huh.
-So you broke it
before you landed?
-Yeah.
-You were mid-air and broke it?
-Yeah, and then I kind of landed
and kind of laughed it off,
and I finished the show,
then I went back and realized
that it was broken.
-Uh-huh.
-That sounds like
something you would do.
The adrenaline would get you
moving through the thing.
-That sounds like
something you would do, too,
'cause you've been injured,
like, a couple times
when I've been here at the show.
-Yeah, I think I've actually
done this exact thing.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But I didn't expect people
to catch.
I just jumped into an empty...
-Right.
An empty pool, yeah.
-It's kind of your thing.
-Yeah, it's like "Squid Game."
My life.
That's, like, based on my life.
-This sounds pretty believable.
-I know, but that's how tricky
this dude's brain is.
He would think that --
I think he's so advanced.
He's -- He's an actual actor.
-Yeah, he's smarter than
both of us put together, right?
-He's smarter than both of us
to-- Yeah, he is.
So I feel like he would be like,
"Oh, Jimmy will fall for this.
I stage dove. I broke my leg."
And you would --
Look at the way he's acting now.
-I think he's --
I think it's true.
-Wow.
-What do you think?
-Yeah, I'm gonna go with you.
I think it is true.
You did embarrassingly do this.
-It is false.
-Ohh!
Guy's unbelievable.
He's un-- He's levels.
He's levels above us.
My thanks to my pals
Chelsea Handler, Finn Wolfhard.